the future of our european union is also
written in ukraine
and therefore
today i would like to speak about two
topics
first about sanctions
and second about relief and
reconstruction for ukraine
today we are presenting our sixth
package of sanctions
first we are listing high-ranking
military officers and individuals who
committed war crimes in bucha
we know who you are we will hold you
accountable you're not getting away with
this
second
we finally d swift spare bank
spare bank is one of the is the largest
russian bank it holds round about 37
percent of the whole banking sector
and we will also de-swift to other major
banks in russia
third
we're banning three big russian
state-owned broadcasters from our
airwaves
we have identified these tv channels as
mouthpieces
that amplify putin's lies and
propaganda aggressively today we are
addressing our dependency on russian oil
and let's be clear
it will not be easy
because some member states are strongly
dependent on russian oil
but we simply have to do it
so today we will propose
to ban all russian oil from europe
we will make sure that we phase out
russian oil in an orderly fashion this
is why we will phase out russian supply
of crude oil within six months
and refined products by the end of the
year
thus we maximize the pressure pressure
on russia
while at the same time and this is
important we minimize the collateral
damage to us and our partners around the
globe because to help ukraine
we have to make sure that our economy
remains strong
we want ukraine to win this world
but we also want to set the condition
for ukraine's success in the aftermath
of the war
and this is my second point relief and
reconstruction
the first step is immediate relief this
is about short-term economic support
to help ukraine cope with the fallout of
the war
so much has to be rebuilt
europe has a very special responsibility
towards ukraine
with our support
ukraine can rebuild their country for
the next generation
and this is why today i propose to you
that we start working on an ambitious
recovery package for our ukrainian
friends
if we do it right
this package should bring massive
investments
to meet the needs and the necessary
reforms in parallel and this will bring
the stability and the certainty
that is needed to make ukraine an
attractive destination for foreign
direct investment
and eventually honorable members
it will pave the way
for ukraine's future inside the european
union